So motives are the drive or reason for doing what we do and emotion is the
feeling of good or bad about our experience. So as it turns out emotions can be
motivating and motivations can be emotional. So for instance, when you're happy
or proud that's telling you you're doing the right thing, keep it up. When
you're afraid, that's telling you, you're in danger, get out of the situation.
Or, if you have a really great meal, that brings pleasure, or happiness. And
then, when you're disgusted, or angry, there's no way for you to be sexually
aroused. So as you can see from these simple examples, emotion and motivation
can be closely connected to one another. As we'll see later on in the lesson,
this is often because the brain structures involved in motivation and emotion
are often nearby. But for now, let's just move on to the question, what is
emotion?